tyler glass now goes to the hill for the
raise still looking for that first win
this will be his sixth start of the year
and strike three call
he got him looking on the breaking ball
here's renato nunez 283 on the year for
him five homers
[Applause]
that's hit well down the left field line
and it's gone just snuck it right at the
315 sign and renato
well we were just saying about time and
there it is home run number six and he
got glass now in that home series here
against uh the reigns so there you go
glass now now he's taken him deep twice
six home runs on the year tommy malone
really has been the most consistent
starter as far as getting into the
middle of ball games four one three
earned run average through the 21 or 25
punch-outs just three walks on the year
and i think his pattern of setting
hitters up with the fastballs in and the
change up there it is
away is just a money sequence
[Applause]
and takes a strike right there and he
can sit down boom
wow great scene
yeah 3-1 next pitch a swinging a rocket
out towards left field going over is
mason williams he makes a sliding catch
going towards the warning track he hauls
it in and lau left on base and mount
castle waiting in the on deck area the
pitch on its way breaking ball swung on
miss strike three and
that one had some bite to it cisco just
swung right through it and there's
quickly two going here in the second so
here's hunter renfro
oh a long one deep to left and that baby
is out of here
home run by renfro
and boy can he get a hold of a pitch
he got hold of that one the ball comes
off his bat with a different sound
and the raise
on the fifth home run of the year for
renfro
will take a 2-1 lead
[Applause]
here's margot hitting one deep to left
that's got something on it and that one
is gone
home run from argo
back to back renfro and margot
i'm going to keep talking about the
throw from valencia because as soon as i
do it razor hitting home runs i mean
another bomb by manuel margot
he gets him swinging third strikeout of
the game for malone
ground ball off the glove and that's
grabbed by a diamond still to first
got him oh my
glass now just got a little piece of
that one and adamus got over their back
of the bag
right field side to make a great pick up
and throw
and what makes it even more impressive
is the runner
santander
and he is out on strikes
that fastball with some low heat down
there
and a swing and a miss at the breaking
ball he got ahead of all three hitters
there in the third it's a one two three
inning
[Music]
[Applause]
one one
hit to center field mullins is there
drifting back well wait a minute i
thought he was oh man wow
didn't get back there quick enough but
used his speed those last couple of
steps to make the play
[Applause]
hit hard into right field base hit
alberto around second he's into third
and the orioles have a little something
going here with one down runners on the
corners
i saw that one up and there's a base hit
and ryan montcastle has his first major
league rbi as hancer alberto comes home
two on and the lead cut to three to two
why what a nice piece of it you talk
about a in it bat adjustments uh
and a swing and a miss that's gonna take
care of a leica and the orioles
i can come there too and then i can do
that to you and throw you that change up
and then you can sit down yeah
absolutely yeah well executed right
there brush it back gets ahead i think
is the most important and really that's
the beauty of it so malone can tell
hitters yeah the change of helmet right
now yep got him with the fastball and
satugo strikes out for the second time
in this game back back to back gaze in
the inning so he's thinking about this
change up down there
and the fastball gets blown right by it
how about that strikes out the side
tommy malone has set down the last eight
three-two race
and a swing and a mess he is out on
strikes tell you that curveball
tyler glass now spins that thing so
tight
and and both of these guys too they
pitch angry yep
santander is out on strikes
and a swing and a miss he strikes out
nunez
zanino will have to go down to first to
complete it
and so glass now strikes out the side
bottom of the fifth coming 3-2 rays
what they're capable of
and there's a swing and a miss
and another strikeout
that's five consecutive strikeouts for
glasnost
and a swing and a miss he strikes out
cisco
fly ball into right toward the line
santander is going to be there make the
catch here's a tag at third rinpro's
gonna try to score and he will
rinfro coming in head first
and the raids add a run to make it 4-2
choi will get credit for the sacrifice
fly
and a cut and a
on council is out of there so that's six
and a third for glass now
with 11 strikeouts
swinging and a miss 97
with that fastball
and that's a dozen 12 strikeouts for
glass now
strike three call
98 on the outside corner as he strikes
out the side here in the seventh inning
steps on the bag and the raise win this
one
it's a 4-2 final
no runs ahead and the man left in the
ninth inning and the rays win
their 20th game of the year
as glasnow will pick up his first win of
the year
[Music]